police and protesters scuffled outside
the Old Bailey in London emotions have
been running high throughout this case
these far-right demonstrators clamored
for the killers to be hanged in contrast
a dignified appearance by Rigby's family
as they arrived at court in witness
impact statements they told the judge of
the difficulties they faced in coming to
terms with Lee's death a police family
liaison officer spoke after the
sentencing today the Rigby family
welcomes the whole life and significant
sentences that have been passed down on
Lee's killers we feel that now of a
sentence would have been acceptable and
we would like to thank the judge and the
courts for handing down what we believe
to be the right prison terms the judge
told Michael adebolajo here on the left
that he would die in jail Michael
adebolajo will serve at least 45 years
behind bars
the two men were removed from court
after becoming unruly both were
convicted of murder in December security
camera footage of the attack showed Rick
Dees body in the road with his killers
pacing about nearby the two then tried
to attack police but was shot and
wounded both men described themselves as
soldiers of Allah taking revenge on
British soldiers leading Muslims in
Britain were outspoken in their
condemnation of the killing sentencing
was delayed while the judge sought
clarity on whether whole life sentences
without parole were compatible with
European law earlier this month
Britain's Court of Appeals ruled that
was the case